[Music]
what is up everybody its Anna Mack here
for anime uproar and in this video I
will be talking about a hidden crisis
that is facing the world within which
the story of boku no hero is taking
place this could lead to an outright
catastrophe in the not so distant future
and this hidden crisis has already been
alluded to in the story and it is likely
going to play a major role in future
arcs I think that this crisis has been
deliberately set up by ma che creator
Kohei horikoshi in order to give himself
room to continue raising the stakes as
the story goes on and I am excited to
talk about all the different
possibilities in this video I also asked
you guys on Twitter and Instagram to
help me out by giving me some input for
this video and I will be reading some of
those at the end of the video if you
want to be featured in a future video be
sure to follow us on Twitter and
Instagram at anime out Pro and of course
if you like this type of boku no hero
content you can leave a like to let me
know and if you're new to the channel
don't forget to subscribe and Detroit
smash that notification bell I have to
warn you now that in order to talk about
this hidden crisis I have to talk about
events from the manga that have not yet
been covered in the anime so spoiler
warning proceed with caution in Chapter
166 of the manga this looming crisis is
mentioned directly in a conversation
between present Mike and Shi ketsu high
school students AGC Sakura
present Mike is expressing his shock
with how powerful some kids from an
elementary school already are and how
strong their quirks are because at their
age present Mike wasn't able to
demonstrate that kind of power
Seiji responds by saying that there is a
line of thinking or a school of thought
however you want to put it that as the
generations pass quirks are going to
keep mixing together as they are passed
on from parents to their children and as
these words continue to mix and combine
they will become stronger and more
complex in fact the quirks might become
so powerful that no one is going to be
able to control them anymore which could
lead to a terrible crisis and apps
disasterous people lose control of their
insanely powerful quirks the school of
thought that promotes this idea refers
to it as quirk singularity now we may be
tempted to think that this is just a
throwaway line by say gee who does have
a flair for the dramatic but the fact
that Eddy and her quark rewind have been
featured so prominently in the story in
the last few arcs tells us that there is
much more to this Eddy is a little girl
who possesses a quirk unlike anything
that anyone has seen before her quirk
allows her to rewind another person's
body to a previous state an individual
who is touching arrey directly when she
activates her quirk will have their
bodies return to a previous state and
the reason that deku manages to defeat
chisaki AKA overhaul is because Eddy was
holding on to him and allowing him to
use 100% of one for all power since
whenever dec who used that and damaged
his body area squirt would rewind his
body back to when he was no longer
injured Airy squirt rewind is so strong
that she sake was using her blood to
create bullets that would make their
targets lose the ability to use their
quirk because their bodies would be
rewound to a time before their quirk had
even manifested on top of that Airy
squirt can rewind a person's body too
before they even existed literally
wiping them out of existence in a flash
when she was younger
Eddy accidentally erased her own father
out of existence because she didn't have
control over her quirk and because area
is still a child and she is unable to
control her quirk we still don't know
its true potential but she sucky
believes that once she masters her quirk
arrey could use it to devolve the entire
human race to its primal state airy is
the most blatant example so far of the
next generation of quirks which are
becoming more powerful to the extent
that the user cannot even control them
and as a result people get hurt like in
this case Ares father and of course
works with this kind of power can be
taken advantage of and abused as Chucky
did by experimenting on area to create
quirky racing bullets and if chisaki is
right and Ares quark has the potential
- rewind not just a single person but
potentially even all of humanity then we
can only imagine the chaos and
destruction such a quirk could cause if
he lost complete control over it
or if it got into the wrong hands like
for example if all for one somehow
managed to steal it and now that I think
about it actually it makes perfect sense
that the doctor whom deku visited as a
child would be the same doctor who is
working for all for one all for one
knows that the next generation of
children are likely to possess more
powerful quirks so he is using the
doctor to locate the quirks in order to
steal them for more on the connection
between Dec whose doctor and all for one
check out my full video on it link is in
the description so if we combine the
fact that young children are developing
stronger quirks from the previous
generation with how Airy was born with
an incredibly overpowered quirk that she
has lost control of multiple times it
seems clear that the concept of quirk
singularity is not just a throwaway line
Chouteau Todoroki is another good
example of someone with a next-gen court
his quirk is a combination of his
mother's ice based quirk and his
father's fire based quirk but now
imagine Shoto having children with
someone like to you and suddenly their
child is able to use fire and ice
attacks while at the same time being
able to move like a frog combining
incredible offensive power with amazing
agility on the one hand this is really
cool and the many interesting quirk
combinations are endless but on the
other children suddenly manifesting
insanely overpowered quirks that they
cannot control can lead to a major
crisis and widespread destruction and on
top of that if any of these overpowered
quirks are stolen by all-4-one or the
children themselves decide to become
villains it creates a drastically bigger
challenge for all the heroes imagine
someone manifesting a quirk like space
hero 13's black hole but even more
dangerous and harder to control or a
quirk that can control time or cause all
volcanoes in the world to erupt at the
same time if things continue going in
this direction and we already have
quirks like Ares appearing then what is
going to happen in a few more
generations
we could be looking at quirks that cause
a major global catastrophes and
completely destroyed the world of boku
no hero as we know it at the same time
the fact that the quirk singularity
concept has been introduced allows
horikoshi a lot of room to grow in terms
of the narrative no matter how powerful
Deku and the rest of the heroes become a
new overpowered quirk can always emerge
to pose a fresh challenge to them this
will keep the story interesting as long
as it is handled in the right way and as
long as we don't see the kind of sudden
and rapid power escalation that is
unsustainable in the long run personally
I like this concept of quirk singularity
and the many new possibilities that it
opens up for the future with all the
different quirks mixing but I think that
the key will be making sure that we
don't jump the shark and suddenly see
ultra powerful quirks popping up
everywhere at once as long as the
process is gradual enough to provide new
challenges for the heroes as they get
stronger without pushing the heroes to
get strong at a rate that is unrealistic
and feels contrived I think that this
looming hidden crisis of the quirk
singularity can turn into a major plot
point in the later arcs of the boku no
hero story and if executed the right way
these arcs have the potential to be
extremely interesting even hundreds of
chapters from now but let me know what
you guys think do you agree that a
crisis is coming to the world of boku no
hero a crisis that was already alluded
to by sage II as the quirk singularity
concept feel free to give me your input
in the comments and on social media the
other day I asked you guys on Twitter
and Instagram to give me ideas about
powerful new quirks that could emerge in
the future and here are some of my
favorite responses and by the way if you
want to give me input for a future video
don't forget to follow us on Twitter and
Instagram at anime uproar over on
Twitter it's also a gun suggested a
quirk called elemental the quirk is
basically like Totoro keys quirk except
only Fire and Ice it can control earth
air fire water ice and electricity and
combine them to cause devastating
attacks at patriotic mechs American says
so basically you're the Third Hokage and
Brooklyn Brinker says or the avatar and
yeah I agree that this work is
reminiscent of other powers that already
exist out there like the Ovid
our powers but this is definitely the
type of thing that I had in mind what I
was talking about next-gen quirks and
quirks singularity if enough quirks keep
getting passed down by parents to
children and they all keep mixing many
different quirks converge into one oh
peak work
Kevin ARMA had this same idea on
Instagram and personally I am definitely
looking forward to the appearance of
avatar the last quirk bender Daniel and
Kagame 360 both had the idea for a quirk
that can create new quirks I think that
this is an insanely cool idea we know
that all for one can steal quirks and
combine them with each other inside his
own body or the bodies of others but
imagine being able to create whatever
quirk you wish and give it either to
yourself or to someone else
that would be unbelievably Opie but
again that's the whole point of the
quirk singularity problem especially if
a villain gets their hands on this type
of quirk j02 suggests a time controlling
quirk called paws which is similar to do
Brando stand the world and it lets the
user pause time for up to 10 seconds but
for every second paused it takes away
one hour from their lifespan in a
previous video I already said that I
really like ideas about time related
quirks especially when they have some
sort of limitation like in this case
time-based quirks can really cause chaos
and change the game in battles so this
will definitely qualify as an Opie
next-gen quirk and we also had multiple
people suggesting a time stopping type
of quirk over on Instagram as well
nock stock who had an Opie Kirk idea the
secret technique passed down the Joestar
family line for generations
running the eff away and you don't have
to say F Knox I'm trying to stay
family-friendly here man you want to get
me in trouble so the YouTube gets mad at
me and then takes one of my thumbnails
down and puts best guy ever face on it
come on man and my boy grape juice adds
on to that saying minute ah already has
that quirk he used it against midnight
all in all both of these comments speak
for themselves all I have to say is good
work boys good work over on Instagram my
switch life is trash wants to see a
memory alteration quirk the user just
has to look at the person they want to
alter the memories
and their memories can be changed into
anything I think this is a lot like
Emperor Charles's Geass from cold Geass
and I definitely like the idea because
if you can alter someone's memories in
reality you can change their entire
personality and manipulate them to do
whatever you want a villain with this
type of work would be a huge challenge
for any hero
oh when Duggan's suggests a quirk that
lets people grow to 15 meters tall by
drawing blood and being determined they
can also heal by emitting steam from
wounds and use different techniques also
they can pass on their quirk by being
eaten oh wait that's a Titan shifter and
yes good one sir good one vs ufh a
suggest sack were called dimensional
teleportation the user can teleport
through different dimensions and he can
even create small dimensions in one of
these dimensions he stores weapons and
can summon them during combat this
reminds me of Gilgamesh's gate of
Babylon and this would definitely be an
Obi power that could create a Gilgamesh
level epic character very cool idea and
pimp shrimp 2 for 7 great name by the
way suggests a quirk that does the
opposite of Ares by aging people at
different rates depending on the power
output the ability to speed up the aging
of people and maybe even objects would
be an incredible power for sure you
could make people crumble into dust and
potentially even do the same thing to
entire buildings
if this quirk can also be used on
objects again this is another quirk that
seems more fitting for a villain than a
hero but with that said it could be
absolutely awesome if done right and
that's all the comments I can get to
right now but a big thank you to
everyone who gave me their input really
great ideas some of your ideas actually
matched up exactly with existing quirks
in the manga so I didn't mention those
and I don't want to talk about them
directly in case I spoiled this story
for you but still really great feedback
overall if you enjoyed this type of
content and you'd like to see more be
sure to leave a like to let me know if
you happen to be new to this channel
don't forget to subscribe and Detroit
smash that notification bell as always
thank you all so much for watching I
really appreciate it and until next time
see ya space cowboys
[Music]
you
[Music]